my name is Luis Rivera and I was
originally sentenced to life without
parole plus 140 years and I served 30
years in the federal system my name is
Antoinette Frank a lot of people call me
Tony I spent 11 and a half years but I
had a 15 year 8 month sentence my name
is Barbara Scrivener and I spent 20
years 11 months and 3 days
incarcerated in prison on a 30-year
sentence
I was young I went in at 27 years old I
was a pilot learning to fly involved in
aircraft sales and unfortunately I took
the wrong route and went the other way I
got involved in drugs and transporting
drugs from Colombia to the United States
mostly just cocaine I was an automobile
dealer in Delaware Ohio had a Chevrolet
Cadillac store I saw approximately 3,000
cars are while I was in business
twelve of those cars were sold to people
who turned out to be drug dealers and I
transferred some titles from Georgia to
Ohio for this group of people and the
government contended that I helped them
succeed in that drug business that I
either knew or should have known that
they were drug dealers in high school I
kind of became a drug addict and then I
would hang out with men that were kind
of abusive and had drugs and so I pretty
much spent a lot of time just partying
and not really caring about much and I
met this one man kind of same situation
and then I bi married him and then I
became pregnant
and then I thought wow okay so now I
have a purpose in life
we would fly to Colombia and they would
load up the airplane with about roughly
250 kilos and it was brought back into
the United States
we'd unload it and transported back to
someplace like Miami and secretly handed
over generally you would be something
like you just leave it in a car in a
parking lot and the owner would come by
and pick it up you know and then you'd
get paid for it it's very lucrative I
was at our automobile dealers convention
in San Francisco and so my staff called
and said that FBI and some other the DEA
had been in the dealership asking
questions and I feel I thought it was
sort of ludicrous I didn't think I would
be indicted for that this is something
that would blow over and you know I'll
be cleared but that was the farthest
thing from the truth
so my husband was 11 years older and he
was a heroin addict he was involved with
some friends of his that would
manufacture meth and they would sell the
meth and then they would buy heroin and
they would get high in party they jury
found me guilty of conspiracy and I
guess in their eyes they believed that I
knew what was going on no matter if I
knew what was going on if I wasn't no
part of it then it didn't have anything
to do with me so being found guilty of
conspiracy that charge makes you liable
for every single thing that anybody ever
did you kind of think what is this a
mistake you know this is here you're
kidding here and I remember at
sentencing when they brought me in for
it then the judge took a break he said
excuse me we have to take care of
something and then he brought me in and
you know they the lawyers all remain
seated and he proceeded in sentencing me
and after he slapped a gavel and he left
you know all the other lawyers got up
and walked over to where we were and
said hey that's ridiculous he can't do
that and so I had that in my head that
you know you know this was wrong they
had said something in the papers cuz I
was all over the papers I was the
headline I was the black part of my beer
dealer which was something unusual
specially female in the eighties so the
news had said from 30 years to life and
all kind of stuff they threw out I
didn't actually know until I got to
court
day that I would receive 188 months in
prison and I had no idea of what any of
that meant until I got to prison and
started and that's when it really sunk
in as to the severity of the sentence
during the trial my attorney was telling
me they can sentence you to 30 years in
prison and I still it did not compute
even when I was finally sentenced to 30
years I still didn't believe it I'm
still in my mind thinking this is not
happening there's no way I'm doing 30
years in prison it makes no sense as
governor michael dukakis vetoed
mandatory sentences for drug dealers
he vetoed the death penalty everybody
wants to be tough on crime and that was
the mantra the injured to be tough on
crime presidential elections were lost
because people say they weren't tough
enough on crime I was not a gangster and
most of the people that I worked with
never carried any guns we didn't rely on
any kind of violence or threats and it
was just too much money you know the
opportunity was there and when I say
money I mean Millions
it finally really hit me that um yeah
I'm gonna do 30 years in prison and no I
do not want to do 30 years in prison
there's no way
I was in FCI Tallahassee at the time and
they have these really tall buildings
and I got on the roof of one of the
buildings and I took a razor blade and I
cut my throat and I jumped off and they
came and they took me to the hospital I
was DOA on arrival and I spent four
months in the hospital pretty much with
everything broken I had like seven
surgeries to repair everything they
thought I would be paralyzed I'd learn
how to walk all over again and well and
I was in the hospital in those four
months realizing okay well I I did pull
through this and now I might be
paralyzed spending thirty years in
prison that's not even that doesn't make
the situation better I realized you know
I'm gonna have to try to figure out the
best way to you know get through this
because this is a reality and I am gonna
spend thirty years in prison and you
know how am I gonna deal with this once
you exhaust your appeals that you've
been in courts don't want to hear from
you anymore even if they've made the
mistake they don't care they don't want
you back but the federal government
through the the prosecutor the US
Attorney's Office has the power to bring
you back at any time and they determined
that you know I did enough time my
warden had come to me and said Barbara I
want you to know that yesterday the
pardons office called and said that they
were going to grant you your clemency
and what I thought about it and I just
fell apartment was right there in the
middle of food service and had just felt
tears started coming in I just like are
you serious I mean just two weeks ago I
was thinking you know I still had you
know six seven years left in prison and
now you're telling me in two weeks I'm
gonna go home ain't it's not happening
no way it's happening and two weeks
later I walked out those doors
so I called my sister and she said your
name is not only listen great and I said
don't look at the party look at the
commutation and my name was on the list
I was in the phone booth
and she was just screaming to the top of
her voice and I just started crying I
was down 30 years and I got out in
October so I've been down almost six
months out I've been free almost six
months now
and I'm just enjoying every day what
does that mean what is enjoying every
day
I can't wait to wake up in the morning